all right Bob we got this let's go as I
tell you what you did there Bob why
arrow Ronnie the entire internet has
seen that yeah plenty of people will get
their money how are you to pay here for
ain't no money I have no money you are
old man
what no money that's not even like
quoted I hear leanness no the same era
baby Wow no it's just horrifying it's a
horror Hotel in the filled with horror
some really scary [ __ ] going on what is
that sound in that room that's a baby
it's the baby I was just like the all
the all retail reference episode which
one it's really love delayed but you're
gonna like the way you find me
I guarantee it what are you talking
about Bob makes sense I'm doing random
advertisement references from my life
that people are probably completely
unaware of there's gonna be like three
people oh I thought you were doing like
a parody that an episode did a parody of
some show oh you're gonna like the way
you find me I think you're gonna like it
you're gonna like the way yes I'm in the
open
Wow that that really just did not go
well for me and you did you straight-up
just didn't notice are you [ __ ]
kidding me
did I just wreck you marker did you get
me found elsewhere no no I was I was a
chair in the middle of the hallway they
walked by me like 20 times I could I
count that as its Jack walked around the
corner I flipped over the coffee table
and standing there in the store Oh God
idiot I would have not died but I'm an
idiot
Wow she got you in the end Bob what you
went through a wall cool I suppose so
you [ __ ] cheater
this is gonna be good they're never
going to look here to find this are you
[ __ ] tease me what where what what I
don't know but they're cheating
basically the base are you still like
through the wall [ __ ] no no no I went
through the wall and he went through the
wall he went completely through he went
clear straight through oh yeah bull whoa
yeah no trust me I saw him and I would
never cheat you actually see me go
through I didn't see you go through but
I saw you running around after how we
get downstairs what's going on there's a
basement area you can see I know I
haven't yet how are you supposed to get
to the basement area I'm sort of stairs
I only see upstairs there's like a it's
like a great here probably I can't Jack
I do you see this did you just yeah what
what what
oh yeah oh oh oh it's like it's like
Super Mario 64 there was that wall in
the back of the house you didn't make it
back out yeah oh oh my god oh whoa where
am I
oh it's very cheesy this is my boy I can
we just jump in the hole in the wall for
a while oh my god Zach you'd bought
floating in my face it's so cute
oh no I can't see him anymore I made it
I'm trying to push you Bob okay I don't
like that I just got birth out of marks
hole hi are you going there baby oh god
it hurts
if you turn the camera at certain angles
yellow engulfs the entire map so we have
all you 40 seconds left so oh yeah as we
should have been playing the game parody
of a broken map
yeah whatever sound broken it's fully
functional just don't do that hey hey
hey what's up oh my god wait wait where
are you oh crap he went to the other
side is he still here oh wait don't run
away be my friend the holes off-limits
that's crazy yeah you can't you can't
own a hole now you can't own a hole like
you can opponent you can own it but what
if I can't pone it I have a particular
problem with pony that's why jacket I
own it I don't feel like I need you
can't poke a hole I'm not part of your
weird whole owning game are you sure
you're the one that started the whole
loading game I started the club but not
the game that's it that's the specific
distinction huh what even remotely am i
but didn't you just say you started the
club Oh what is that I don't know it's
like a big slipper
oh I know
I know Anna model I know it's great yeah
oh yeah wait no that's not fair Oh Oh
God
Bob oh sorry sorry he's a shoe he's a
dill he's in there cuz it dill dude he's
a dude we're in that room I'm not giving
you more of a hint I have a mark mark
doe Oh God
oh wait wait wait wait wait
are you saying that it was a little
early and there was something you could
do about it
Wow premature coming coming that's an
inappropriate joke to make to a third
grader I'm sorry
now this video off YouTube no this video
is gonna be my coming from me going
pretty sure YouTube Terms of Service is
you can't say in the club I wasn't horny
three seconds ago and now you go to your
doctor he's like I'm afraid it's
premature coming coming wait wait
terminal case I'm gonna need a sample
and and see how you're coming coming go
we go account is right now it's you do
just gonna go me go go here um there's
coming coming go going bags all over the
wall
I'm feeling that Bob we're gonna lose
faith in you Bob pain came when when I'm
a professional horse can become ego ego
collected by my bulls is worth like
$8,000 yeah it's it's fascinating we
have this device is called an electric
coming coming go a going machine you
could actually set the speed of your
coming coming Billy oh absolutely that's
the best feature of the KY say one it's
a problem I have all started gives you
prematurely come you come ego ego heed I
always bring a black light to hotel room
so I think there is a basement is you're
not a professional screamer like me
yeah hey my twitter handle has been
professional screamer since like 2012
that too also that I should change that
son I'm king of the girls that's a good
thing
yay yeah I do but I really don't have a
good Matthew McConaughey impression
butcher 1/2 high skill girls give me
massive I have a grant the big maybe a
little coming coming going I was too
distracted doing my perfect Matthew
McConaughey I think we all seem to take
away from this and really remember the
whole wait oh wait is a premature
ejaculator that's the that's the first
time I've actually made it into the hole
oh my god wait wait wait did you just
lose your virginity
I lost my comingcoming GUI GUI what does
that mean oh do it huh I'll do it I want
to do it
can you tell us how can you tell us how
what are you doing I got out of the hole
oh that sounded very like power whoa
whoa whoa whoa zombies down here how'd
you get down there dude boasting right
now I saw it I think I know how to do it
cuz there are some buttons up at the top
that I pressed in the vent okay okay I
know where to go to press the buttons
which opens the trick door what what
what what what hey you guys alright
we're come through oh okay what do we
got what do we got
I think this door let me go Han wait
here
yeah wait there I'm gonna go pray button
oh I'll be all let you know what I'm
about to press the bottom lamb you go
kill blade we don't need them way to
face him if I kill you you can just post
and then it'll be so much easier just
wait no no wait wait wait wait hang on
wait let's talk about this wait yeah
give me a few more seconds I'm away jack
oh you came down here all right here we
go button pressing right now yay
did it work whoa [ __ ] all right well I'm
all out of ideas kill a mob kill them
Jack's code upstairs all right I'm gone
baby as soon as I heard kill him I was
dogs and you waited diapers pause balls
I'm going upstairs pause balls I'm going
downstairs I'm going the other way we're
gonna write it down actually know if he
came out here so wait cuz I think it's
like chained up the damage to you
alright
waiting in holding position don't don't
don't jack dick what do you do what are
you doing where'd he go where to go
where to go where to go where to go
where to go where to go where to go go
I'm trying to help I don't see him
where'd you go down here pretty good
that's the worst pain impression ever oh
I see you
oh damn it he was the kitchen left left
all right I'm out of bombs
he's a bottle I am NOT ass ass to the
left
oh he's behind the I saw him for sex
right now
he's waiting just shoot the bottom left
corner of the wall Oh
bottom right bottom middle it's going
down the stairs he's right there right
on target he won in the baby room they
know ya went down the hole this is
[ __ ] I called no hole I'm not on
your team all right Bob you have eyes on
no I realize now I realize Bob I can't
win at his game I gotta lose it it's not
gonna work oh it might work it might
work okay it's not gonna work not gonna
work that actually kind of might work
can you see me
uh no mm-hmm try try this try this oh
yeah get in there get in there nice and
tight
yeah just turn turn turn turn
can you move toward the wall anymore ah
[ __ ]
I'm well okay I got it almost dead hey
jump jump
damn it Wade [ __ ] you can do it come on
I can't do it man did I move it all oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah turn turn a little
bit I don't know that's that's actually
pretty good
okay you can't help you you sounded like
Ryan I'm said said dr. evil when Scotty
comes back to him hey you're not yeah
all right
if I find you immediately can we laugh
really hard about it
okay I don't think it's gonna happen Bob
yeah yeah it's a little too late for
that
it's I'm still might laugh I am still
might laugh yeah and Bob you do have a
good laugh the internet kind of agrees
want you to find me so I can hear it too
the best around never never gonna keep
you down however that was so long what's
that what I was going for okay mmm I was
trying to think of another song to think
you see those lyrics but all I could
think was that that one song yes best uh
stop this entire round which is
unfortunate because it's not yet singing
um someone will remix it and you'll be
cool
so let's straight away we'll be silent
you sing Oh duck my dick suck my dick
everyone here can't suck my dick I'm
gonna win so suck my dick everyone here
can suck my dick that's it
oh wait Bob where are you I'm upstairs
in the broom on the left in the middle
where there's a bunch of bookshelves
okay and Jack are you super Pro right
now what no you're just dumb oh god I
broke the game again are you like in the
wall and [ __ ] don't you see me don't be
splat no no thank you serious are you in
this room right now
yes I told you guys are you among us
give us a message [ __ ] books for you
oh god he's Bobby's moving the books he
really are yes oh god he killed Bob huh
he's gonna kill me too oh my god